what's going on guys this is rob and may
the fourth be with you yes may the
fourth be with all of you and we are
we're doing some darth vader comics okay
here's the thing for those of you guys
who don't know about the marvel comics
star wars thing that's going on
basically the way this plays out of the
way this works is that when disney got a
hold of star wars they walked they wiped
away all the old expanded universe stuff
which we might cover if you guys are
interested but things like the golden
age of the sith and like the force wars
which are basically like the origin of
the jedi and some of those stories were
cool in place of it what marvel started
doing is they started releasing star
wars comics that tied into the movies so
the first star wars line of comics
follow a new hope and the darth vader
story follows a new hope and then you
get this amazing story called vader down
but uh but then this one right here
right this is technically darth vader
vol 2 although we're calling it vol 1
because it's the first story arc in the
second volume of darth vader uh but
basically this one follows the events of
the empire strikes back so if you guys
remember that empire strikes back movie
that's all you need to know and so what
this does is it initially opens up
following the initial encounter between
vader and luke skywalker when vader told
luke skywalker that he was his father
and as a result of that it's really him
kind of reliving these memories and kind
of focusing on it and of course in the
immediate aftermath of that admiral piet
is like vader the emperor wants to talk
to you and he's like uh i got other
stuff to do and he's just like we gotta
get out of here so he ends up grabbing
the forensics droid and they basically
set off and it even happens before
like admiral piet could really contact
vader now the thing about this is that
where where admiral piet tells the
emperor vader's kind of gone off on his
mission as those of you guys who are
familiar with star wars know the emperor
is really more curious than anything
else but he's also kind of all-knowing
right whether he's seeing things through
the force or simply having eyes and ears
all across the empire there's very
little that escapes the emperor's notice
in terms of why people are doing things
the other part of this is that with this
droid being a forensics droid vader of
course being wildly tech savvy ends up
reprogramming it and then basically
tells it like if you ever tell anybody
about anything or you reveal anything
you've learned on this mission you will
self-destruct right and that's basically
it and so following that the story is a
combination of vader kind of reliving
old memories and at the same time going
on a mission and it makes sense in terms
of the context now the first place they
set off to is ultimately tatooine
because of course vader's looking for
luke skywalker but the funny thing about
this is the further down this path they
go the more vader ends up looking into
his own past and so a lot of what this
story is designed to illustrate i would
surmise is that in return of the jedi
when darth vader turned against the
emperor and sided with luke skywalker
that started long before that particular
moment it wasn't like vader was just
like yes i see the light now and then
sided with luke and like basically those
events unfolded that seemingly it all
started when he first encountered luke
skywalker in person and that's really
what set him down this path of
essentially going back to the light side
what's really told to him by this droid
is that okay uh luke skywalker right
like it's the one that vader wants and
it's like okay like he disappeared
without a trace like we don't know where
he went to but ultimately when vader's
like we'll find him again for now we
have to track down everybody who hid him
from me and destroy all of them and so
the droid surmises the first and best
place to start is tatooine now when
vader arrives there there are some
pirates that are kind of hanging out
basically looking to like essentially
run up on anybody who's just woeful
enough to stow along their path they
will return these poor bastards
[Laughter]
uh yeah like they they well well we'll
talk about we'll get to that when we get
to it of course as you guys know um ever
since the imperial or the empire itself
became aware of tattooing really ended
up sending initially a search party
there it's always they've always kind of
kept a garrison there right just a
handful of imperial guards that
basically keep an eye on the place and
it's always you know tattooing is one of
those places if you follow the old
knights of the old republic games and
the universe surrounding knights of the
old republic tatooine always had some
kind of a garrison there whether it was
the republic or you had like zurger
corporation that operated out of there
for a while or the empire itself they've
always always kind of been a place where
people have just resided and a lot of
that is really just kind of book ending
the uh the role that people play in
tatooine in terms of the significance of
tatooine right like tattooing became a
huge place because luke skywalker came
from there in the old school star wars
films and the content and then the
expanded universe it's always held a
kind of personal place one of those name
mainstay locations that exists in the
star wars mythos it does have a lot of
history there's a lot that's gone on in
tatooine but for this particular point
as we know when it comes to darth vader
anakin skywalker it also holds a
significant place to them because he's
from tatooine or at least uh that's
where he spent most of his life on
tattoo the younger years of his life
before he was rescued by obi-wan kenobi
and qui-gon jinn now one thing that i do
want to point out here darth vader is
currently accompanied by death troopers
let me tell you something man you talk
to anybody who's ever read anything
about death troopers about star wars and
they will tell you man death troopers
are legit if those guys come for your
ass it's curtains these guys are like
the elite guards i mean they have like
vocal scramblers these guys are trained
in everything right heavy weapons like
melee weapons unarmed combat they're
they're basically the personal guards of
the most elite members or the highest
ranking members of the empire now i
would go as far as to say darth vader
may not need them but it's better to
have them and not need them than to need
them and not have them right so again it
is darth vader that we're talking about
here one of the cool things about having
them there is it almost kind of gives us
this more realistic portrayal of vader
that he's not this all-encompassing just
unstoppable force that vader can be
defeated right it doesn't make him this
just you know almost god-like being but
when he arrives there again he starts
experiencing his own memories right
where he was talking with his mother and
his mother's like you know be brave and
don't look back that kind of a thing and
we also get a little bit of history here
now those of you guys who saw episodes
four five and six and one two and three
this is all stuff that you know but
that's one of the great things about the
darth vader comics is it doesn't really
reference anything that you haven't seen
before and so this is probably as much a
trip down memory lane for you and
nostalgia as it is for the character of
darth vader in the comic of course what
we're told is that this was the home of
cli lars and schmie skywalker and that
after their deaths the house was
inherited by clique's son owen lars and
his wife beru and so of course we know
that when it came to shmee and all them
they of course were the parents of
anakin essentially if you want to call
it that kid was technically born to the
force and then of course you have owen
and you have baru who were essentially
the adoptive parents of luke skywalker
so it's a cool little a cool little
segment here but as they go through here
and as vader kind of relives these
memories of course it's basically the
droid going through analyzing everything
and finding that there really isn't a
whole lot for them to cover here there
really isn't a whole lot for them to
find now of course in the midst of all
this it's like there's there's you know
there's no one left and so you have kind
of the graves that are seemingly buried
underground but that's basically it in
terms of the mystery of darth vader
being able to locate luke skywalker
there's nothing here on tatooine that
can bring him that information and so
ultimately what you end up having are
basically these pirates that launched
their attack against darth vader and
these poor bastards pick the wrong time
it is
[Laughter]
you know the george like okay you can't
punish anybody here but i mean you can
kind of punish them and so these guys
basically show up on what is in effect a
pirate mission and uh darth vader makes
it their last one but he helps them
understand their place in the bigger
picture literally when they bombard the
whole place of course darth vader
doesn't die and like literally pulls the
ships down right and then just starts
killing everyone it's amazing like it's
just it's not i mean killing everybody
isn't amazing but it is when darth vader
does it and so literally he just like
slaughters everyone here and then when
the droid asks the question are we done
the response invader is no and so what
they end up doing is basically traveling
to coruscant to what was in effect the
apartment of senator padme amidala right
so again this is what's so cool it's a
trip down memory lane because we hadn't
really seen reference to this ever since
the end of episode three right it was
just kind of like i mean we assumed it
was there but that's the cool thing is a
lot of the questions that you are likely
asking in terms of what happened in the
aftermath of padme's death of anakin
turning to the dark side a lot of that
stuff gets answered in these comics
which is really really really cool but
ultimately of course the droid is kind
of figuring out what we've already known
right that like padme was the mother of
luke skywalker and that a jedi named
anakin skywalker frequently showed up
here now that's one of the things to
specify here no one knows that anakin
skywalker is darth vader well precious
few people know right the emperor knows
and that's more or less kind of it and
then you also have like like luke
skywalker who figures it out but outside
of that no one knows right and that's
one of the crazy things because vader
puts together that only the most trusted
allies of padme would have even known
that she was pregnant and those
individuals had to have been the ones
that took her away from from this
location to whatever it is that she
ended up giving birth and then in turn
the kids were whisked away from there so
it's basically vader kind of tracking
down the location of everything right
figuring out what we as the audience
really kind of already know uh and then
the crazy thing here is as soon as they
make their way past a whole bunch of
these crazy looking monsters and whatnot
uh did they basically end up opening
this door and on the other side of this
door is padme amidala now here's the
thing i was gonna leave you guys on a
cliffhanger when i was initially reading
through this i was like you know what
i'm gonna leave i'm gonna leave him on a
cliffhanger but i'm not going to uh
instead what's really really cool is
that as they get in there to vader's
eyes this is padme right and and of
course you know where you would expect
maybe some kind of an emotional response
keep in mind the emotional part of
anakin skywalker is largely gone right i
wouldn't necessarily say because he's
mostly machine but because he largely
killed that part of himself off as he
was falling to the dark side it doesn't
mean that he's not emotional it just
means it's deeply rooted at the moment
it's just vader as we know him with
maybe some hints of anakin skywalker in
there and so that's when the droid kind
of analyzes and it's like man like the
similarities astonishing she seems to be
the same age as senator amidala would be
if she were still alive superficial
scans reveal a similar bone structure
she even wears naboo style field gear
and and ultimately like the chicks like
why are you here and that's when vader's
like no like do not shoot at me who are
you and she said like you said it
yourself like i'm padme amidala and the
responsive vader is no that is not true
padme amidala is dead i know it i felt
it in the force i know for a fact padme
amidala is dead so i will ask you one
more time who are you and that's when
the droid basically puts it together and
realizes she's one of padme amidala's
handmaidens that she's one of those
women out there who was designed to look
like padme amidala to pass herself off
in case there was like an assassination
attempt or something along those lines
and so that's the cool thing is that
ultimately we end up learning this is
sabe right the queen's double now it's
really really cool because in that
moment that's when vader says okay fine
like years ago on coruscant you broke
into padme's quarters you wanted to find
out what happened to her what did you
learn now this is a really really
important moment because what it shows
us and what it really confirms is what
we had largely suspected and to a degree
kind of knew from the old star wars
movies or from from one two and three
that padme basically kept all of this
hidden from even her own handmaids that
nobody really knew what was going on in
terms of her and like anakin that whole
scene with obi-wan kenobi and everything
all that kind of stuff all of that was
largely basically hidden when she was
whisked away her handmaidens didn't know
and so that's kind of what's been going
on is like they've been literally trying
to figure out what it is that happened
to padme amidala now it's a it's
probably it was originally a mystery
that they intensely dove themselves into
in the early days following the collapse
of the republic and the takeover of the
empire but over the years i wouldn't go
as far as to say they abandoned their
quest but with the empire's reach being
so far it was really one of those things
where it was we investigate as we try to
survive and that was basically it now at
the same time the handmaiden doesn't
fully understand vader's mission because
where vader is here and he was like
before she died she was stolen away and
whoever did that betrayed the empire her
response is why would it matter like it
was the empire in the early days she
never would have worked with you but
it's not like she was an imperial agent
and that's almost kind of how vader
pitches it to a degree not really in so
far as saying that's the case but by
framing it in such a way as saying that
they betrayed the empire by taking padme
amidala away again it seems strange
because if anything the empire would
want padme amidala out of the picture
she's one of the last and really
significant remnants of the old republic
and so it's like you would want her gone
so why would emperor palpatine care if
padme amidala was somehow stolen away
from the empire i guess maybe unless she
had information but if she had some kind
of valuable information it wouldn't make
any difference now because you guys rule
everything like you guys have been
ruling everything for like 20 years so
what difference does it make right and
so ultimately it's just kind of like
okay whatever they end up kind of seeing
eye to eye and that's when vader's like
you serve padme amidala you will serve
me because our mission is in effect the
same you want to know what happened to
her and i want to know who took her away
we are in effect looking for the same
people and so ultimately of course once
they fight off a few more of these these
monster things right that's basically it
they end up taking off right they end up
bailing out now one of the things that i
want to specify here and it's one of the
things that that really is illustrated
here in terms of how vader perceives
everything he knows this woman is not
padme amidala he knows that's not the
case but being with her brings back the
idea of padme amidala so it's almost
like him kind of going through and to a
degree reliving his own experience right
it brings him back to really the the
closest he's been in a long time to
being anakin skywalker this is a very
dangerous road for darth vader to walk
on because this is how fallen jedi those
who fall to the dark side end up you
know how they become dark jedi or sith
lords or what have you this is how they
end up back at the lights side right oo
looking k keldroma is a perfect example
of that that darth vader was not the
first jedi to fall to the dark side and
go back to the light side again and this
is usually how it happens kind of
bringing themselves back refreshing
themselves on the person they used to be
and using that as an anchor to kind of
bring themselves back to the surface
from these deaths that they've spent so
much time in and so once they travel
back to naboo this is again a very
interesting moment for vader because as
this happens he kind of looks around and
these are some pretty fond memories for
him if we're being honest with ourselves
it was in effect the first time that he
ever experienced what it was like to be
in love right with padme amidala it was
the first time he had ever really
experienced that and to actually know a
life of genuine peace without any real
measure of conflict because one of the
things to remember in the aftermath of
him being a kid and taken away from
tattooing from his mom yoda was right
when he said like this is something that
anakin's not going to be able to get get
over very very easily in fact he may
never get over it at all that attachment
that he had to his mom really remained
missing her thinking about her that
really remained the idea of him missing
his mom in such a way kind of took a
backseat to a degree when he met padme
and began to fall in love with her and
so while i wouldn't say he saw her as
like a mother figure that that that kind
of uh motherly love transitioned into a
romantic love but when he had those
moments with padme even though it was
weird seeing him falling through the
grass on naboo even when they when he
had that moment it was basically him
finding a measure of inner peace that he
hadn't necessarily found before and all
that was effectively yanked away right
his fear that she was going to die
during childbirth from those
premonitions that he was having
basically led him down the path of the
dark side so it's him kind of revisiting
this this exceedingly positive and
beautiful moment in his own history and
that's why i say this this story here in
particular is really where marvel and
disney illustrate the idea that vader
was slowly making his way back to the
light side again and so that's kind of
the funny thing because as soon as they
enter into those quarters they're
immediately attacked now of course it's
it's gregar typho and then of course you
have a captain tamra now the guy with
the eye patch you probably remember from
the first three movies right he should
look familiar to you all the guy who
doesn't have the eye patch the white
dude he doesn't really ring a bell but
maybe he should i don't remember the
artistic rendering doesn't really match
the uh the at least i can't accurately
put him to a face for the movies but at
the end of the day of course they're
basically here because sabe had
essentially sent out a signal letting
them know that like she was arriving
here but as soon as they saw vader they
thought she was under duress so that's
the reason why they attacked but the
reason they're here is because there was
information in the apartment of padme
that was taken by sabe and sent to a
secure location this location seemingly
being where it was at or perhaps even
being moved uh but ultimately that's why
they're kind of tracking this down
because now it's no longer about vader
trying to find luke skywalker it's about
vader going down this rabbit hole of
padme what happened to padme right how
did everything go because remember
that's one of the things that vader
didn't fully know that that assuming we
wipe away everything else in the
expanded universe which this was
explained in that but assuming we wipe
away everything from the expanded
universe and we focus explicitly on
essentially the ending of episode three
and then we go into this that he felt
pad may die and the explanation given to
him by the emperor is that essentially
vader himself or anakin himself had been
the one to essentially kill her that at
the end of the day his response was no
she was alive when i like when i left
her like she was she was fine when i
left her and so he never fully believed
the emperor when he said you're the
reason padme died that there had to be
something else that was going on there
and again this is him kind of trying to
find an answer to that question and so
of course as they're making their way
you know underwater in naboo they're
attacked by some underwater creatures
like that's gonna stop darth vader dude
literally busts out his lightsaber and
annihilates them and then they end up in
one of these little underwater bubbles
in naboo and of course they end up
finding what's basically a shrine or a
kind of a kind of gungan construction
that really illustrates the the tribute
to the alliance that padme had formed in
the wake of like the trade federation
invasion so if you guys recall from
episode one when padme had basically
orchestrated an alliance between the
gungans and the uh well really the
republic right that this is really a
tribute to that right so just really
great callbacks to the to the the you
know to episodes one two and three which
were always really cool and so once they
end up locating the missing surveillance
data from padme's apartment uh this is
when you end up finding out the
surveillance data is actually sabe from
shortly after what was believed to be or
at least what was the death of padme
amidala and she literally says like
tonight we start calling ourselves the
amadons and together we pledge to find
whoever murdered our queen and killed
them all so we swear and that's when
vader realizes it's a trap he's like
explain yourselves and they're like we
told you vader the last time we saw
padme she was heading to mustafar to
find skywalker years later we learned
that mustafar was your domain you killed
them again they haven't put together the
fact that darth vader is anakin
skywalker remember no one really knows
that and so that's literally when they
launch an attack or at least intend to
launch an attack they send off this kind
of signal that brings in just like this
this soraa aqua beast right just like
this enormous beast that as far as
they're concerned it's the only thing
that's capable of destroying uh
destroying darth vader of course he ends
up basically falling into its mouth
alongside the droid but let's be honest
as gigantic as this creature is you know
it's not going to destroy darth vader
and in fact it doesn't that while the
droid basically specifies that there is
nothing on the record books that
indicates a way to kill these things
aside from another one of them vader is
darth vader and literally kills it
because you know none of us would
honestly believe that darth vader could
could actually be killed by a sea
monster and so he wins
and the droid's like congratulations
vader you're the first one to accurately
or at least to exist on record to have
destroyed one of these giant bees so
it's kind of a cool little moment right
but nothing major or significant here
but following that they end up traveling
to thee the capital city of naboo and as
soon as they arrive there they're met by
all these amadons right and it's just
like we sentence you to death for the
murder of padme queen and senator of
naboo and general anakin skywalker her
jedi protector and that's when vader is
like did you know them and he says yes
we fought side by side when the trade
federation invaded and that's when you
realize this guy who's talking is
actually the older gentleman that was
initially explaining how the naboo
fighters work to anakin skywalker so
again great callbacks to those old
school films that's one of the reasons
why i love the the darth vader stories
from greg pack now of course these guys
are all idiots right like launching an
attack against darth vader come on it's
never going to work and it doesn't
[Laughter]
it doesn't work like literally he goes
through and just starts attacking
everybody now for the most part vader
himself just kind of deviates and does
his own thing and the the death troopers
are really the ones that take out most
all of those people but that's what's
kind of crazy is that darth vader
essentially killed the guy that he
initially that taught him how to use a
naboo fighter right these close
connections that vader has he kills them
all but one of the things that i want
you guys to notice is that as this
happens right as vader recognizes people
from his past or as he kills people from
his past i want you to kind of notice
the expression that's given here now as
far as vader it's just a helmet but if
you know watching the star wars film you
also know there's a little bit behind
there and that's the cool thing is as
vader does this he realizes he's killing
his own past off and as he does that he
brings himself back to his past self
just a little bit right brings himself a
little bit closer brings back that
connection that that part of himself
that he for so long thought was
basically gone that anakin is slowly
making its way to the surface and so
following that of course you end up
having the amidalans the basically the
handmaidens themselves who all step up
with the intention of taking out vader
we of course know they won't and vader
himself doesn't really even want to kill
them right i mean initially he kind of
you know starts you know fending off
their attacks but it's more of a
defensive uh measure than anything else
because he could kill them all with a
swiftness if he wanted to right
literally force choking throwing his
lightsaber around i mean these girls
would all be annihilated in moments if
vader chose to kill them but he doesn't
now he does use force choke on seemingly
all of them but then he ultimately just
lets them go because it's like i have no
desire to kill any of them right now of
course at the tomb of padme amidala he
does find that little uh that little
artifact that he crafted for padme when
he was a little kid to ensure that she
never forgot about him but at the end of
the day once he cracks open the tomb and
he makes his way in that you initially
have a sabe who comes running in and is
like no you can't do this right you
can't break in here you cannot desecrate
this tomb and instead of him doing it
the droid scans the whole thing and
basically says yeah okay there's a
there's a med implant that was stamped
here she's not in this tune right she's
not here now once the droid kind of
analyzes and it's like okay she is
technically here or at least it seems
like she's here i mean there's no reason
to believe that she wouldn't be vader
can't really bring himself to look at
the body of padme and in fact he can't
even really bring himself to desecrate
the tomb of padme again that anakin
personality kind of riding to the
surface and the fact that he doesn't
want to desecrate the grave of the woman
he loved and so there's a medical
implant that's there which basically
traces them back to where it was that
padme was at when she essentially gave
birth to luke and to leia and so this
starport control of course it was a
rebel base that was previously
discovered by the empire and was
basically just destroyed right or at
least seemed to be destroyed it was
basically bombed so the whole place
wasn't annihilated but everybody who was
in there was either killed or maybe
escaped but as they're going through
they realize you know just from the uh
from the computer systems that there was
a uh a naboo j type star fighter or star
skiff that was transporting padme
amidala and there were two droids on
there alongside obi-wan kenobi and
that's when as the droid is looking at
this and analyzing of course you have
basically the amadons that launch a
secondary attack now with darth vader
having his death troopers at his side
they basically launch an attack from the
side right like quite literally just
kind of catching them off guard and that
for the most part takes out most all of
the ships uh those individuals who do
make it to the surface vader takes them
out as well but this really is a ragtag
bunch that's one of the things that i
really want to specify here the amadons
are not really an organized military
force if anything they're a militia
following the ideologies or following
the namesake of padme amidala and bent
on the idea of trying to get revenge on
whoever it was that essentially killed
her right so thinking of them is like
one step down from the rebel alliance in
effect but of course all these guys are
basically taken out by vader and it's
done pretty brutal right it's it's a
pretty brutal way like he really spares
nobody but as all these forces are taken
out this just leaves vader the death
troopers and the droid and they end up
making their way to a maternity ward and
vader asks like what do the records say
and the response of the droid is the
data core has been destroyed there are
no records here there's nothing to tell
us what happened so this is the
explanation even as part of this journey
why it is vader was not able to easily
figure out that padme had given birth to
luke and leia and where they had been
taken to the only records that really
exist in the first place is the
maternity droid that was helping padme
give birth to leia and luke in the first
place the droid recognizes it's
exceedingly damaged but part of their
memory bank still appears to be intact
and basically what it gives them is this
holographic depiction of padme on the
table seemingly after both kids are born
and it really and the the first words
you hear are what are basically obi-wan
and that's when the droids like that
name again like we've been hearing that
name ah that person must have been very
important to her and vader almost kind
of takes it as an affront right because
remember vader has a hatred towards
obi-wan and a lot of this is really
rooted seemingly in the skewed
perspective of the dark side remember in
like the third movie he was he like
literally looked at padme and he was
like you were with him more so than that
he sees obi-wan as basically the one who
turned padme against him in the first
place that anakin legitimately believed
he could get padme to rule the galaxy
alongside him and they could kill the
emperor it was a pretty twisted
perspective that anakin had but him
being really the only one there
witnessing this while the death troopers
stand outside that the hologram
basically says there's still good in him
like i know that there's still good in
him and so in effect this is really
where the seeds are initially planted
and the fact that anakin's still in
there somewhere he's not as easily
accessible right he's not as much to the
surface as we previously thought there
was but he's still in there and this is
what sets the stage for ultimately luke
skywalker being able to bring that
anakin part of him out during during
return of the jedi the real question you
have to ask here is what happens when
the emperor realizes what it is that
darth vader has been doing because
literally he makes his way back to the
emperor and when he gets there the
emperor's like have you settled your
business and the responsive vader is yes
and the emperor says really have you now
right the sith know that fear leads to
anger anger leads to hate and hate leads
to strength but you my friend have just
wallowed in grief now you have to start
all over again vader with fear and this
is when the emperor starts conjuring
forced lightning and he unleashes a
pretty unholy punishment on this guy
it's an amazing story it's like a little
two-part story it's phenomenal but he
unleashes hell on this guy with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end let me know if you want to see
more darth vader and i will catch you
all later
peace